Narrator: It's been 10 years
since "Shark Tank"
ignited America's
entrepreneurial spirit,
and we're still blazing
a trail
for those who take their fate
into their own hands.
Tonight, Sara Blakely,
the founder of Spanx
and one of the wealthiest
self‐made women in the world,
returns to the Tank.
I also like to invest
in female entrepreneurs.
Oh, my gosh.
Look, we wish you the best,
but I think we're done here.
Do not shut it down.
What's going on
in all those heads over there?
‐It's like Christmas.
‐[ Laughs ]
You will get
your money back.
This is coo‐coo.
I believe that my company
can easily be
a hundred‐million‐dollar
company.
Ouch.
You just love money.
[ Winces ]
You deserve an
"Ay, Chihuahua! Caramba!"
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a better way
to carry your essentials.
♪♪
Hi, there.
I'm Meredith Jurica,
and I am the owner
of Makeup Junkie Bags,
and I'm here today
seeking $200,000
for 15% of my company.
I have created
the most multifunctional bag
a person can own.
You see, I've always been
knee‐deep in beauty products,
but storing my obsession
proved to be difficult,
especially when traveling.
I couldn't find what I needed,
so I made myself one.
Mm.
I wanted it to lay
completely flat on a surface,
unlike traditional bags
that dump over,
sending product
all over the counter.
I wanted it to be leak‐proof.
I have
a leak‐resistant interior,
and I use fabric so beautiful,
you can even double it
as a clutch
for a night out.
Everybody asks me
where I got my bag.
They couldn't find them
anywhere,
so I knew
I had something special.
I put one picture
on social media.
It went viral.
I'd solved a problem
so many people had,
and the bags started flying.
One day, a store called me
and said...
"Do you wholesale?"
Uh...
I frantically searched.
[ Chuckles ]
"What is 'wholesale'?"
[ Laughter ]
"We absolutely do.
How can I help you?"
Same thing when I landed
my first small franchise.
The buyer called and said,
"And we assume
that you barcode."
"Hold, please."
[ Laughter ]
"What is 'barcoding'?
Oh.
Absolutely.
What else do you need?"
I quickly turned
my one‐woman sewing show
into a full‐blown
"Made in the USA" operation
now carried
by 1,200 stores nationwide.
My only business coaches are
the free sites on the Internet.
I need a mentor, an investor,
which is why I'm here.
So, tell me, guys.
Do I have this deal...
in the bag?
[ Laughter ]
I have samples for you.
Great presentation.
Thank you.
And these are yours
to keep.
Take them home
and stuff them,
and then you'll get
the magic.
There you go.
Can't wait.
What an assortment.
Yes, ma'am.
Lovely. Thank you.
And Lori.
Mix‐and‐match
of sizes, prints.
Thank you very much.
Mr. Wonderful.
Ah! Wonder bags.
They look more like purses
than bags.
That's very nice.
Sara, hi.
Blakely: Thank you.
‐Mark.
‐It's like Christmas!
[ Laughs ]
Jurica: So, I was sewing these
in my kitchen.
The first 12 weeks I started,
I did over $100,000 in sales,
just me
at my little kitchen table.
[ Applause ]
‐Yay.
‐Wow.
Greiner: Wow.
Congrats.
Jurica:
So, the lay‐flat design,
it has max‐capacity storage
while taking up no space
in a travel item,
and then I have a men's line
called Man Junk.
[ Laughs ]
Man Junk!
Yeah.
So what are your sales
right now?
I'm about 18 months old,
and I'm at
about $1.15 million.
‐Good for you.
‐Whoa!
It's about time we got somebody
who knows how to sell on here.
Thank you.
You deserve
an "Ay, Chihuahua! Caramba!"
Thank you.
That's unbelievable.
I make these in‐house.
I tried out a small manufacturer
who had horrible quality,
crooked zippers,
and I'm like,
"I can't sell this."
I'm a details person.
Every detail matters.
And he was very rude to me,
and he said,
"The only way to control
your quality
is to manufacture yourself."
And I said, "Sir, yes, sir."
I bought industrial equipment
with all of my profits,
hired seamstresses,
and we make over 6,000 bags
a month now
in Houston in my building.
Wow.
This is a three‐clap
presentation so far.
That's a first.
O'Leary: Wow.
Wow, wow, wow.
So, what does it cost you
to make this one and this one?
Okay,
so it's the medium one.
The black and pink in your
hand's gonna be about $6.75.
Wow.
The large one's gonna be
closer to $7.50
just for the extra fabric.
‐And what do you sell this for?
‐And what do you sell it for?
We're 90% wholesale,
and so that bag
wholesales for $24,
and it retails for $50.
You have great margins.
Thank you.
Do you own 100% of the company
right now?
I do.
We're a debt‐free company.
I had my little nest‐egg
that my sweet husband gave me.
It was actually a down payment
he was gonna get
a new truck for,
and he was like, "You really
think you can sell these bags?"
And I'm like, "Look at
how many orders I got, honey."
[ Chuckles ]
Three months later,
he got a new job in Houston ‐‐
he's in the oil field ‐‐
and they gave him this, like,
decked‐out,
brand‐new sales truck.
That's karma.
And I was like,
"Holy, guacamole, wow."
[ Laughter ]
Meredith, like, okay,
you're doing great.
Yeah.
So, as someone who,
I've owned Spanx for 18 years,
I own 100% of it still.
So, here's the deal.
It's a big decision
to give up equity.
It is, and I thought about it
long and hard.
I want to increase
my production,
whether it's in the USA,
whether it's overseas,
because, today, if
a big‐box store walked up to me,
and they were like,
"Oh, we love it.
We love it.
Let us have it."
I would say, "You can have it.
I can't make it."
[ Laughs ] Because I can make
about 6,000 a month,
and we sell out all the time.
But so many
in the fashion space,
over the decade
of "Shark Tank"
have heard that call
to go into big box,
to go into retail...
Yeah.
...only to be slaughtered
later.
Are you hell‐bent
in going into retail?
Right now, because that's what
the bread and butter
comes from, it is, so...
Yeah, but I'm not talking
about these boutiques
that are paying you, I bet,
pretty quickly.
Mm‐hmm.
I'm talking
about the big boxes.
Yeah.
They eat people like you
like a snack.
So, on top of trying
to get the big fish,
I also want
brand awareness.
I want women to understand
how wonderful these are.
I've talked to all these
PR companies who say,
"Girl, we can get your product
floating into the universe.
I just need a $5,000 a month
retainer, is all I need."
Well, I can't sink
that much cash in
when I'm a cash‐based business.
‐Wait, wait, wait.
How many words a minute
do you talk?
[ Laughter ]
Well, Barbara, I don't have
the data on that right now.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I think?
What you're doing
is thinking
that "short on cash"
is a liability.
It's not.
It's a great asset.
I remember
as a young businesswoman
never having near the money
to match my dreams,
but it was because I had
to spend every penny so wisely
that made me secure
in my footing,
and made me grow
a big business.
I would suggest
you maybe look at yourself
as having
the whole shooting match.
‐Ch‐ch.
‐We don't see entrepreneurs
that are as phenomenal
as you are...
Thank you. Thank you.
...with a great product.
So, I would be unconscionable
going in with you,
'cause I don't think
you need anybody,
so I'm out.
So, what I'm hearing you say
is your biggest challenge
is being able
to provide the product.
Your demand is greater
than your ability to make it.
Yes.
So I would spend
all of your time
solving that problem.
I'm not gonna offer you,
because I want you to keep
your business,
so I'm out.
What's going on in all those
heads over there, you guys?
[ Laughter ]
Meredith,
I'll keep it simple.
You're amazing,
but your business is not one
I can relate to.
I'm out.
♪♪
O'Leary:
What are you gonna do, Lori?
Well...
You know, Meredith...
I was going to say...
I'm out.
‐Okay.
‐But...
...you changed my mind.
So you know
what time it is?
It's deal time.
Boom, boom.
Let's go. Let's go.
Boom. [ Laughs ]
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Lori was going to go out
on Meredith's
cosmetic‐bag business,
Makeup Junkie Bags,
but she had
a change of heart.
What changed my mind 100%
was you.
Ah.
You.
Smart idea.
I know ‐‐
Thank you.
I know
we can sell these.
You are such
a can‐do person,
that I would love to have you
as a partner.
Thank you, Lori.
So, I'm gonna give you
the $200,000...
Okay.
...as a loan.
I get $1 per bag,
in perpetuity...
Ooh.
...and just 5%
of the company.
So, one second.
Before we go anywhere,
I want to help you squeeze
Lori's head a little bit,
because, you know,
I am the king of royalties,
but also, something
you didn't know, Meredith,
I am a fashionista.
Really?
In my own bag,
I have a makeup bag
for television.
That's why I look so spectacular
all the time.
I do my own makeup.
I'm gonna use
one of your bags.
But I think it's very expensive
what she's structured there.
No, it's not.
Royalties in perpetuity ‐‐
nasty, nasty.
I would do a deal with you,
a buck‐fifty a bag,
but ‐‐
I give you the $200,000 ‐‐
after I get back $750,000,
it goes away,
and all I want of the business
is 3%.
So, that way ‐‐
5%, 3% ‐‐
No, the point is...
He wants to $700,000...
...you have a royalty forever
there.
...and he's not helping you
manufacture...
You should push back
saying...
...or do anything.
...after she's got a decent
return on her capital ‐‐
Corcoran: Meredith, I have
nothing to gain here.
I'm out, right?
Did you come in here
for a loan today,
or did you come in here
for cash?
Um, I came in here for money
of any kind.
[ Laughter ]
So...
I really love you.
[ Laughs ]
Oh, my goodness.
Let me tell her
why I structured it this way.
I'll come in,
and I'll be able to give you
all of
my manufacturing resources,
help you with design.
I make bags already,
so I'm like
the perfect partner
to help you manufacture
overseas,
bring it in,
and do all of that.
O'Leary: How do you know Lori's
gonna care about your bag
more than
her other bags?
I don't have a bag company
in my portfolio.
Because I care about
all my entrepreneurs
more than me.
I ‐‐
You would be my only bag.
Blakely: Oh, my God.
Are you charging interest
on your loan?
5%,
'cause I want to squeeze
his head a little bit more.
So let's ‐‐
Now you understand that offer.
I'm only asking for 3% equity
in the company.
Those are the two offers.
What do you want to do?
Blakely: So, I'm gonna jump back
in here for a second.
The problem ‐‐
‐Uh‐oh.
‐Because...
I don't want you
to give up any equity.
So, I would loan you
$200,000.
I would want
a dollar a bag back
until the loan is repaid.
So, this is coo‐coo.
You know
it's not just a loan.
It's everything
that I bring to the table.
Jurica: It's more than that ‐‐
the contacts, the growth.
By helping you ‐‐ Yes.
‐All of that.
‐We've heard all that already.
But it's contacts,
it's my show on QVC.
Look, you have
three offers now.
You understand them?
I do understand
each of them.
I ‐‐
Now you have to make
a decision, Meredith.
Sara, for the loan,
with no equity in the company,
what can you offer
as far as contacts,
manufacturing help,
getting my name out there,
things like that?
Since you're not getting
any equity back from it,
I would just worry
that it's, like, you know,
"Here's your check,
sweetie.
Now get your little butt
on out there and do it."
You know what I mean?
Like...
Blakely: In this deal
and what I offered,
if you're wanting a lot
of my time and energy on this,
it won't be to the degree that
Lori would be able to offer.
I'm just throwing something
in the mix
to make you really think
long and hard
on do you want
to give up equity.
Lori, would you do 75 cents
a bag since it's forever?
Don't do that, Meredith,
Meredith.
Greiner: Um...
Damn, that's a ‐‐
♪♪
Yes. I would.
Let's do it.
[ Applause ]
‐Okay.
‐Oh, my gosh.
[ Laughs ]
You're a spitfire.
Y'all are not as scary
as everybody said you were.
Pleasure.
Pleasure. Thank you.
‐Nice job.
‐Congratulations.
Good job, Meredith.
Great presentation.
‐Good job.
‐Thank you, Lori.
♪♪
Oh, my gosh.
That was crazy.
I went with Lori
because she wanted equity,
she even dropped
her royalty price,
and she told me exactly
how she would be present
in the deal as a partner,
and that's what
I'm looking for.
10 years ago, my brother
sold his car for $6,000.
We were barely surviving.
And thanks to "Shark Tank"
and our partnership
with Barbara,
our business is thriving.
And the ride to work
is a lot more fun.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up
are entrepreneurs who believe
women should not have
to pay more
for the same products as men.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Iskra.
I'm originally from Bulgaria,
and now I live in San Diego.
Hello, my name is Brian,
and I'm the man
behind this woman.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐We are seeking $300,000
in exchange
for 10% of our company.
Angel Shave Club.
Shave clubs are great.
They offer quality razors
delivered to your door
at prices
way less than retail,
but why do they only cater to me
and not my wife?
Why do my pretty pink razors
cost more?
Because of a little something
called the pink tax.
The pink tax refers
to the extra amount of money
that women are charged
for essentially
the same products that men use.
Women's personal‐care products,
including razors,
cost 13% more
than a man's.
That is just wrong.
[ Laughs ]
I like being a woman.
I just don't like
being charged for it.
I was a shave‐club member
for years,
and I used to buy extra
men's razors for Iskra
because they were
so much cheaper,
but, because they were
almost identical,
she would grab mine
by mistake.
I had an epiphany.
And, just like
any brilliant idea,
the concept of our company
was born in the shower.
[ Laughter ]
Angel Shave Club ‐‐
a shave club for women.
We're fighting the pink tax
one shave at a time,
making it so every woman
can be her own guardian angel.
Sharks, you're going
to love our razors
and our shaving products.
We have samples
for everyone.
[ Laughter ]
Now, what we have here is
our flagship product,
our box that our customers get
when they first order.
We send out
subscription razors
bimonthly
and every four months,
depending on the frequency
that they choose
when they first sign up.
They can choose a quantity
of six razors or eight.
So, answer me this.
I look at this,
and, other than the pink handle,
it's the same thing.
Why not just use
a man's shaver?
Because we like pink,
and we want our razors
to reflect the personalities
of our customers.
I had a razor like his,
and I couldn't tell them
apart.
Put a little pink sticker
on one,
no sticker on the other.
And not only that...
Would you say the cost
is the same, though?
The cost is exactly
the same.
Like, if it's yours,
but it's pretty pink,
and it just feels
more feminine.
Exactly.
But apples to apples,
it's equal?
Actually, our razors
are really, really good.
I don't know, ladies,
if you shave at night,
the next day you're already
kind of stubbly.
With our razors,
actually,
you're just
as if you just shaved.
What would keep the people,
the big players in this space,
from just coming out
with a pink razor?
Nothing,
and we welcome
all competition,
however, they are still
man‐owned
and man‐run companies.
We are the first shave club
that's started by women
with women in mind.
Do you have
any customers now?
We've been a business
for two years.
We have close
to 9,000 customers.
Those 9,000 have been,
on average,
how long with you?
Four to six
billing cycles.
What's your turn?
How many have fallen off,
stopped using you?
For a long time?
We have
a turn rate of ‐‐
it's 10% to 12% monthly.
Tsenkova: Every month.
And the number‐one reason
is because
people have
too many blades,
and they eventually quit,
but we're actually
rebuilding the site
to include
a better pause feature.
So, wait. How many blades
do you get in a month?
We send a box
of six or eight.
And it's expected
to last how long?
I'm just curious.
That's two months...
This is two months.
...or four months,
depending on the woman.
Did you ever tell us
what it costs?
It's $18 either every two months
or every four months.
There's another issue,
is there not?
The stubble on a man's chin
is extremely tough on steel.
It dulls it very quickly.
Not so
with women's leg hair.
You haven't met
my legs.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, Barbara.
But they get three times
more usage
out of one blade.
Is that true?
We might not shave
as often,
however, we have a larger
square‐footage to cover,
so, ideally, a woman would have
to change her blade ‐‐
Yeah, but you've been
doing this a while now.
You literally turn over
your entire subscription base
every eight
to ten months.
There's either too many blades,
or something else is wrong.
What does it cost you
to make it?
So, the flagship box
where you get razors
and a handle,
and then the repeats
plus the shipping,
it's gonna be $10.
That's not a lot
of gross dollars,
and it's expensive.
But that being said,
our first nine months,
we did $74,000 in sales.
Last year, we closed
at just over $390,000.
This year ‐‐
So, you've built, like,
a very nice business
for yourself.
Yeah.
O'Leary: But you're not making
any money.
You're not making any money,
are you?
We're reinvesting absolutely
everything that comes in.
We would actually be able
to fund for the whole year,
but the problem is
our supply chain
currently right now
is 90‐day lead times.
That's the reason
why we can't take profits,
because we have to put every
single dollar we have into...
And then some.
Guys, the challenge,
as you know,
is, in terms of cash,
it takes a lot of cash,
because, at 10 bucks a month,
9,000 subscribers,
$90,000 a month,
you're gonna have
to spend 10x of that
just to acquire enough customers
to really be successful.
Actually,
our customer acquisition cost
is not that high.
It's not so much
the customer‐acquisition cost.
It's that
you turn so much.
We are putting practices
in place
to actually reduce
that turn rate,
because we think that
by putting
a pause feature in,
maybe we'll even
allow women to,
instead of two months
or four months,
we'll even do
a six‐month option.
Okay, why are you worth
$3 million?
We're on track to do about
$700,000 this year in sales.
We're already at $220,000
as of today.
So we're actually almost double
what we did last year.
Even if you hit
the $700k‐mark,
which would be great
in just the top‐line growth,
you still won't be
making any money.
But this is
the type of business
you can do
ridiculous numbers.
It's not like
we're gonna sell 1,000 units
and make a huge profit.
We're gonna sell 100,000 units
and make a profit.
So, I like
subscription boxes,
to receive them.
I think it's fun.
But usually there's, like,
a bit of a surprise inside.
Here, it's the same thing
that I'm getting all the time.
Yeah, you got to shave.
That's the idea.
Well, no, I get
that you've got to shave,
but I want every month
to be something different,
and that's not what
you're all about.
You're all about replenishment
and shaving.
I don't feel like it's good
for me to be a partner
when I want to change
what you're doing,
so for that reason,
I'm out.
So, I ‐‐
Thank you so much, Lori.
However, I will try
and bring you back in.
♪♪
I, for one,
am not your customer.
I like to shave my legs
once a month.
These blades you gave me,
I'm gonna use
for the next 10 years.
It's great.
[ Laughter ]
I'm thinking there's really
no need for this.
There is a need.
There must be.
Okay.
I don't get it,
so for that reason, I'm out.
‐Thank you. I appreciate it.
‐I just want to be clear.
I'm gonna explain to you
why you're not worth $3 million.
You make no money.
The enterprise value
of these clubs
is based on
the subscription service,
and you need hundreds
of thousands of customers
before you start
cash flowing.
And then there's always the hope
that you can sell them
other stuff
once they become
consistent buyers.
That's how these clubs work.
It's just brutal.
For an investor
to get back their $300,000 ‐‐
which I consider money.
You will get
your money back.
You would not be
the first entrepreneur
to come in the Shark Tank
and tell me
I'll get my money back.
I haven't heard one say,
"You'll never get
your money back."
[ Laughter ]
That never happens.
I just want to explain,
essentially,
the goal of this shave club
is to be the one‐stop shop
for everything skin care
a woman needs.
Cuban:
But that's obvious, right?
You want to sell more
to your customers.
The problem is,
in order to get
to where you need to go
or want to go,
it's gonna take
a lot more cash.
And I haven't seen
a marketing approach
that tells me,
"These guys
have got it nailed,
just a little bit of cash."
And so for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thank you.
We do have such great ideas
for marketing.
Are there other
women's shave clubs?
Do you have competition?
I think there's maybe
one or two,
but we're the leader
in the space.
Yeah.
Nobody has
more than 9,000 subscribers.
I mean, who knows
what they have?
'Cause we don't know.
But I mean, we know
that where we market,
we don't ever see them.
It's commendable,
but I got to tell you.
I don't want to go
on this journey with you.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you.
But you still have...
Me.
So, I would use
this service.
I'm ‐‐ I'm a woman who forgets
to buy my razors,
but my biggest issue
is that there are big companies
that have done this
in a major way
and have a huge market share,
and it's too easy for them
to suddenly start
catering to women.
For that reason, I'm out.
Appreciate it.
However, this is
such a tremendous,
enormous industry,
and women are going to want
to come to us.
They are.
Look,
we wish you the best,
but I think
we're done here.
Thank you so much.
Okay. Thank you,
we appreciate it.
Thank you.
Good luck, guys.
Take your angel
with you.
Blakely: [ Laughs ]
Not quite what we expected
at all.
I ‐‐ That's gonna be
their loss,
because we're gonna kill
this market.
♪♪
[ Engine starts, revs ]
What is happening?
What's that?
♪♪
Well, hello, there.
[ Laughter ]
‐Hey, guys.
‐Whew.
That's an entrance.
Hey, Sharks.
‐Hi.
I'm Nikki Linn.
I'm Rusty Niedwick.
We're from Basalt, Colorado,
and we're asking for $200,000
in exchange for
20% of our company,
Kitty Kasas.
That's right, Sharks,
we're just a couple
of tattooed bikers
that have a serious soft ‐‐
soft spot for the kitties.
We were so frustrated
by the lack of
quality pet products.
There had to be something better
out there.
There was nothing.
Something cleanable...
Nope.
...stackable...
Negative.
...durable...
Not even close.
...and so Kitty Kasas
was born.
That's right.
Kitty Kasas are a modular,
stackable cube system
for your cat.
You can use them
individually,
or you can stack up
multiple cubes
in hundreds
of different ways.
And they're super cute
and modern
and come in tons
of different colors.
And they're
virtually indestructible.
So, who wants
to help us...
Both:
Claw our way to the top?
[ Applause ]
‐Whoo!
‐Well done.
So, let's talk
about Kitty sales.
How much have you sold
of these things?
$600,000.
‐Okay.
‐Over what period?
‐Over what time period?
Year and a half,
two years.
We had a ‐‐ We had a hiccup
in our second year
when we had partnered
with a plastics company.
There wasn't a lot
of sales.
What about last quarter,
last three months?
Well, last three months,
we're at $200,000.
Oh, good for you.
How'd you guys get
into this?
We've run a no‐kill
animal shelter for 20 years.
‐Oh, wow.
‐Good for you.
And ‐‐ Thank you.
After going through
every product on the market
that was ever made,
there was nothing like this.
We really made it
for ourselves,
and then everyone
who adopted a cat
came in and said,
"Oh, I want to buy one
of those cute little things,"
and then we put them on our
shelter website and sold out.
And then we said,
"Maybe this could be a company."
It just sort of grew
from there.
This was really just a solution
to cleaning the cat rooms.
We can take these outside,
we can put them in bleach,
we can power wash them,
and you just can't do that
with carpet and cardboard.
So, like, I'm a cat lover.
I've had a lot of cats.
[ Gasps ] Yay!
They like it because
it's a little enclosed space.
Like, they're always going
into little tight spaces.
They love it.
It's a whole new scene
for the cats.
And what does it cost you
to make a unit?
We have
three different prices.
The bedroom is about
10 bucks.
The one with the scratching post
is 11 bucks,
and the third one,
the little top bed,
is about five bucks.
Okay, and what do you
sell those for?
$39, $49, and $22.99.
So you should be making ‐‐
you guys are making money, then.
Uh...
This year.
[ Both laugh ]
We've been ‐‐
The first quarter,
if you did $200,000 in sales
mostly direct
with the margins you have...
We're doing mostly ‐‐
mostly direct.
But you said you had problems
in your second year.
Our second year,
we had a very big problem.
We were doing
these rotation‐molded cubes,
and we took them
to a design show in Germany.
We had a very large
plastics company approach us ‐‐
they are huge ‐‐
and they basically said,
"We're gonna take
your product,
and we're gonna turn it
into an injection mold.
You're gonna buy
from us.
You can use our distribution
network in the US,
and we'll give you a royalty
for European sales."
They strung us along
for a year,
and then basically stole all
the intellectual property...
At the last ‐‐
So they took it all...
...at the last minute.
...and gave you nothing.
Yes.
We had to walk away
from that deal.
We had to spend
the next year
building our own molds,
redesigning everything.
Wait a minute.
Do you have a patent?
We do.
Why haven't you done
cease and desist?
We have.
We did.
And?
Our choices were,
"You pursue this billion‐dollar
European plastics company..."
‐Right.
‐$2 billion.
I'd like to know what you want
to do with the money.
Um, expand.
It's Nikki and I,
and we have one IT guy.
Okay.
And the big box stores
that we have done,
it's tricky, and the logistics
are very, very difficult.
But ‐‐ But why do you have
to go into big‐box stores?
We don't. We absolutely ‐‐
We absolutely don't.
‐So, do you need ‐‐
‐These margins don't work.
Do you need the money
for support?
Is that where you would deploy
the money?
Additional support and employees
would absolutely be wonderful
to help with expansion
and sales.
That's probably our biggest ‐‐
biggest hurdle at this point.
Corcoran:
And if you weren't gonna go
into the retail space,
how would you use
the money?
Redo the website,
continue to build out
our social media.
I like to invest in people
who are passionate
about what
they get involved in,
and clearly you're
very passionate about cats,
but I am allergic
to cats.
I don't have a cat.
I don't know enough
about this space,
so I wish you guys the best,
but I'm out.
Thank you, Sara.
Thank you.
O'Leary: When I look
at the margins,
you don't make a lot of money
selling to retail.
That's the problem.
No.
I don't like retail
for this.
I don't like
the size of the product.
That's exactly why we went
to that box versus the...
No, I know, but it takes up
a lot of floor space.
But this thing
is very interesting.
On a direct‐to‐consumer basis,
the numbers work.
Look, I like it.
I'll make you an offer.
♪♪
Narrator: One Shark is out,
but Kevin seems interested
in Nikki and Rusty's
cat shelters, Kitty Kasas.
There's two of you.
I want to be the third partner.
I want 33.3%,
and I'll give you $200k,
and I will help you blow this up
direct‐to‐consumer.
Wow.
And you make a deal
with the cat devil.
‐Wow.
‐I love cats.
And by the way,
cats love me, too.
I want to know
what the cat lover thinks.
Well, when you go to ship them,
they don't collapse at all.
These do.
Those do?
Can you show us?
These fit
in this retail box.
Oh, my gosh.
What does it cost, then,
for your shipping and handling?
The shipping and handling
is around $6 or $7.
Lori, what are you doing?
I'm talking.
I'm asking questions.
Well, I'm just saying.
Look, you know,
one of the things
that I start to feel ‐‐
I'm not loved,
and when I don't feel loved ‐‐
You should be used to it,
Kevin.
Kevin, we have to give Lori
a chance.
She loves cats.
‐That's right.
‐If Lori wants to compete...
That's right.
...bring it forward.
I'm trying to help her
move along.
Corcoran:
While she's debating
whether she's going in
or going out,
I'm gonna drop out
for one reason only ‐‐
I hate cats.
[ Winces ]
When I was very young,
I found a cat in my bed.
I had no idea
how it got there.
[ Laughter ]
That was
the freakiest thing
that ever happened to me,
to have a cat right there.
I can't get over it.
This isn't for me.
I'm out.
Okay, I'm gonna make you
an offer.
O'Leary:
This is really exciting.
[ Laughs ]
This would be
the first time
a cat actually died,
it waited so long.
Okay.
While she's doing that, guys,
my brother loves cats.
My brother posts
947 cat pictures a day.
Can we send your brother
some free samples?
I love your brother!
Yes. But I hate the cat
and pet business.
Brutal business.
For those reasons,
I'm out.
Understood.
Lori, while we're still young,
please.
Greiner: Um...
I think that potentially
I could sell this well on QVC,
for one big reason ‐‐
so many pet lovers.
I'm gonna make you
an offer.
$200k for 33.3%
just because
he's such a cat hater.
So I'm going to match
exactly what he did.
You're not doing them
any favors.
Lori, would you do 25%?
I would like to be
an equal partner with you.
You want a partner that's gonna
be in the trenches with you.
Absolutely.
Yeah, absolutely.
I feel really good
about the 33.3%
so that we're all
equal partners.
Um ‐‐
She has no creativity.
♪♪
How about 30%, Lori?
Done.
Deal!
[ Laughs ]
Yeah!
Yay, cats for us!
That is awesome.
Oh, my gosh.
Thank you, Lori.
Yeah!
Thank you!
Oh, my God.
[ Laughs ]
Yeah!
Linn:
This means everything to us.
Niedwick:
It's incredible.
Three years ago,
this was nothing,
and now we have a deal with Lori
on "Shark Tank."
I'm really heartbroken.
I got to tell you.
You cannot do a deal
with something
where you hate
the animal.
No, I love the animals.
You don't.
You just love money.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Narrator: In Season 8,
Renaldo Webb pitched Pet Plate,
a healthy pet food
delivery service,
and left without a deal.
I'm living this right now
with Plated.
They've learned the hard way
how difficult it is to scale.
Let's see
what he's up to now.
♪♪
Webb: When I walked
out of the Tank without a deal,
I was so frustrated.
But after "Shark Tank,"
I received over $50,000
in Pet Plate orders,
and we needed
to make 10,000 pounds of food.
I was able to move
the production
out of my commercial kitchen
to a production facility
that was able to make thousands
of pounds of food per day.
But scaling so quickly
created some serious problems.
The facility was
heavily automated,
and it was hard to ensure
the product quality.
It was a disaster,
and if there was one point
I thought Pet Plate would go
out of business, it was then.
A lot of our loyal customers
weren't happy,
and I knew I needed
to fix the problem.
When I was looking
for a new facility,
I thought about Kevin's doubts
on how I would scale Pet Plate,
and that really resonated.
It wasn't just about scaling.
It was about scaling
responsibly,
and I needed to find a facility
that could make the food
in a similar manner
to how I made it
in Brooklyn.
I was able to find
the perfect facility
that was able to provide
the volume
as well as the product quality
our customers had grown used to,
and that's when Pet Plate
really took off.
What's everyone think?
This is good.
Today, Pet Plate has
thousands of customers
all across the country,
and we've done
over $4.2 million in sales
in the two years
since "Shark Tank."
I can't believe
just two years ago
I was delivering Pet Plate
on my bike
just in New York City,
and now we're shipping
all across the country.
What matters most
is we've helped
thousands of dogs
improve their health.
They've overcome
digestive issues,
food allergies,
and poor appetite
just by eating real food.
It would've never happened
without "Shark Tank"
and the Sharks' tough advice.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a business
with a mission
of making it easier for moms
to have quality time
with their kids.
♪♪
Wow, you mean business.
Hello.
My name is Whitney Lundeen,
and I'm from
Palo Alto, California.
My business is Sonnet James,
and I am seeking $350,000
for 25% equity.
It is so important for parents
to play with their kids,
but too often,
our clothes hold us back
from our parenting adventures.
Well, Sharks,
I'm here to tell you
it doesn't have to be that way
anymore.
I'm the mother of two messy,
wiggly, beautiful boys.
To them, grass stains are just
a sign of a day well‐spent.
But on my clothes,
they're an expensive
dry‐cleaning bill
just waiting to happen.
I thought,
"What if there was a dress
that made it easy
for moms
to get down
on their kids' level
and immerse themselves
in their adventures
but also made them feel
confident and attractive?"
If you're a mom
tired of yoga pants like I was,
then this is
your new mom uniform.
They feel like pajamas
but will make you look and feel
put together.
You can head to the city
for a work meeting,
take your 2‐year‐old
on a bike ride,
pick up the boys
from baseball practice,
and go straight to date night
with your husband
without ever having to change.
And the best part ‐‐
when those banana hands
have been wiped clean
on your dress,
just throw it in the wash,
and you're good to go.
Cute.
Help me build a world
where parents are
more young‐at‐heart,
present in the moment,
and more playful
with the ones they love.
Our kids are still young,
but the days of being invited
on their adventures
are running out.
Thank you so much
for your time,
and I would love to share
some samples with you.
Greiner: Great.
♪♪
Lundeen: This one is for you,
Barbara...
Corcoran:
Thank you, Whitney.
...'cause you look amazing
in the blue.
Which one?
Corcoran: Oh, thank you.
I love blue.
Lundeen: And for Lori.
And this is for
your lovely wife, Linda.
Thank you.
That's great.
‐That one's for you.
‐Thank you.
‐Appreciate it.
‐And then that's for Tiffany.
Thank you.
You gave me a lollipop.
Okay, they're nice and thick
and heavy.
Yes, so they're
flattering, yes.
Durable.
They have that nice little
stretch, but compression.
Also, they don't seem as though
they'll lose their shape at all.
I'm pulling, and that thing
will go right back.
Yeah, they retain their shape
really, really well.
So, what does this cost?
For me to make is $34.
I make locally in California,
and I sell it, on average,
at $138,
and so my margins
are about 75%.
‐Wow.
‐Wow, that's great.
And where do you
sell it?
I'm direct‐to‐consumer.
Everything's on ‐‐
Everything's online.
O'Leary:
On my website.
And by the way,
marketing was great.
You know, the videos ‐‐
Oh, you have a shirt?
No, it's ‐‐
I think it's a dress.
It's a long dress, yeah.
‐Oh.
‐Yeah, it's my...
Please, I'm gonna wear it later,
Lori.
Leave it alone.
[ Laughs ]
Put it on right now.
But, Whitney, I'm always
enamored with numbers.
You know that.
I love numbers.
Yes, I know that.
So, $350,000, 25%,
$1.4 million valuation.
Yeah.
You got to be selling
a lot of this stuff, right?
I've been in business
for five years now.
My first year,
I did $84,000.
Good for you.
$84,000, first year ‐‐
that was five years ago.
‐Five years ago.
‐Okay.
And this last year,
I did $1.2 million in sales.
‐Whoa!
‐Yay!
‐That's awesome.
‐Wow!
All online.
‐All online.
‐How did you get that much?
So you've built
a community of mothers
that are into
what you're doing.
They buy more than one
from you.
Yes, my average order
is two dresses,
so that's around $250.
Wow.
Do they repeat order
from you?
Do they say, "I love it"?
I have a 43%
returning‐customer rate.
Your sales are great, so
obviously something's working.
‐Yeah.
‐But are you making money,
or are you spending
a lot of money on marketing?
‐Yeah, so...
‐What's your cash situation?
Lundeen: ...I do ‐‐
I do feel like I need help.
I feel like my margins
are so good,
and then I feel like my COG
is good.
COG is
"cost of goods sold."
Yes.
And then my expenses
are closer to, like, 63%,
where my COG's like 27%,
and then I only have
about 8% to 10% left
for my net profit,
which I just feel like
is too small.
Blakely:
You're the designer?
I have designed
every single dress, yes.
And what's
your background?
I had kids young.
I was 22 when I had
my first child,
and I decided to be
a stay‐home mom.
And fairly soon after,
I became a single mom.
I was going through
a difficult time in my life,
and so I had this idea
of making a dress
that my mom could have worn
that could've reminded her
to play with me
when I was little.
Then I said, "All right,
this year,
I'm gonna take the idea,
and I'm going to teach myself
how to sew,
and I'm gonna pattern draft,
and every night
I would pretty much
sit on the kitchen floor crying,
trying to teach myself
how to do two things
that I had no idea how to do.
And, uh, I built the website,
and, surprisingly,
a mom blogger picked it up,
and she thought
it was a really cute idea.
And within 48 hours,
I had over 150 orders.
‐Wow.
‐So cool.
And I completely
freaked out.
And I called my brother.
I said, "I am shutting
the website down.
I'm gonna refund
everyone's order,
'cause I have no idea
how to deliver 150 dresses.
And he said,
"Do not shut it down."
Like, this is what start‐ups
dream of, you know?
Greiner:
Yeah. That's right.
And I was like, "Okay."
He talked me down,
and I got in the car
the next day,
and I drove to L. A.
'cause I had heard
that there was fashion‐y stuff
in L. A.,
and I just started
knocking on doors,
and the rest is
kind of history.
Good for you.
Can I go back
to one thing on your story?
Yeah.
You said you were gonna
design a dress
that would be like a dress
that if your mother
had played with you?
‐Yeah.
‐Can you expand on that?
Yeah, so, um, I had
a somewhat difficult childhood.
Um, there was...
Um...
[ Voice breaking ] There was
some abuse and addiction.
And, you know,
it was tough as a kid.
I'm sorry.
No, it's okay.
My parents...
My parents did the best
they could
with what they had,
you know?
[ Normal voice ]
I found when I became a mom,
I couldn't engage with my kids
as much as I wanted to,
and, um, I wanted something
that could help me
be the mother
that I'd always wanted to be
and something that could,
you know, remind me every day
when I put it on
what my priorities were.
And I feel like that's what
mothers connect with, you know?
All of us have come
from some dysfunction, you know?
No one's childhood was perfect.
And I think
this band of us mothers,
we're saying, you know,
we want to do our very best.
And any way I can
support mothers in doing that
is my life goal,
and my mission.
And I feel very honored
that I am able to do what I do.
Greiner: You know what?
How fantastic
that you took adversity...
Blakely: Yeah.
...and you said,
"That's not gonna pull me down.
It's only gonna
rise me up."
Thank you, Lori.
And you did
a fantastic job of it.
You should feel
very proud of yourself.
‐Yeah.
‐Thank you, I am.
‐Absolutely.
‐I am very proud.
It's a very moving story,
I got to tell you.
Now, back to numbers.
[ Laughter ]
Let's do it.
I love the numbers.
Blakely: How did I know
that was gonna happen.
No, no, no, no, listen.
I'm moved.
I really am.
But $1.2 million,
which is spectacular,
I know it's working.
But that 8% to 10%
you're making
means you're basically making
about $100,000.
Are you paying yourself
anything?
$70,000 ‐‐ that's after.
Okay, so that's after
the $70,000.
‐Yeah.
‐So the challenge here is,
$100,000 on
a $1.4 million valuation...
Is a great,
great valuation.
Not really.
I think I did
a very, very conservative...
It's very fair.
Yeah, yeah.
...valuation.
Why do you think
it's conservative?
Because I feel like,
I mean,
I believe that my company
can easily be
a hundred‐million‐dollar
company.
Yeah, but everybody
experiences returns
in the clothing business.
Everybody loses customers.
I mean, what ‐‐
Yes, I have 23% return rate,
which is lower
than the average of 30%.
‐Ouch.
‐For online...
‐That's huge.
‐Online, it's not bad.
‐So, Whitney.
‐Yes, Sara.
I'm in this business.
Yes, you are.
And what I see is
there isn't a huge
point of difference
in what you're offering
from the apparel side.
Okay.
Okay?
There's lots of items
and products like this
all over the market.
Okay.
23% return rate
is a little high
for how democratic of a fit
this is.
Okay.
O'Leary: What does
"democratic fit" mean?
It means it's flexible.
It's a forgiving...
Yeah.
...garment, right?
See, you learn something
every day on "Shark Tank."
But I also like to invest
in female entrepreneurs,
and I just really
like you.
Thank you so much, Sara.
So...
What are you gonna do?
So, Whitney,
I'm gonna offer you, uh,
the $350,000 for 25%.
‐Oh, my gosh.
‐What?
‐Wow.
‐Thank you so much.
I would say yes
before someone ‐‐
I'm taking it. I'm taking it.
I'm taking it.
[ Laughter ]
You can't change your mind.
[ Laughs ]
[ Stammers ]
Yes, yes, yes.
You're adorable.
Oh, my gosh.
Corcoran: She is adorable.
No doubt.
I'll be able to help you.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, it's great.
Yay!
‐Good job.
‐Wow.
‐All right.
‐Congratulations.
‐Congrats, Whitney.
‐Thank you.
After 10 years
of "Shark Tank,"
you've won the number‐one
presentation for fashion.
Thank you, Kevin.
It was such a crazy story.
Crazy story.
Oh, my gosh.
I mean,
it really, really hit me.
Give him a sucker,
and something happens.
But, Whitney, that was
a ridiculous valuation.
A ridiculous valuation.
‐Good night!
‐Good luck.
Greiner: Bye.
[ Both squealing ]
Oh, my gosh!
[ Laughs ]
Five years
of so much hard work,
and it sort of all feels like
it was for this moment.
Whoo!
That was great.
Aww.
It makes me want to cry.
You're as sweet
as she is.
‐Ahh!
‐Good deal.
Blakely: [ Chuckles ]
♪♪